it's opening day for lee canyon
yes i mean we've been waiting for this
normally uh lee canyon in past years has
opened uh on by thanksgiving if we've
had good enough snow but this season has
been challenging so three of the eight
slopes open 9 a.m to 4 p.m i don't
believe you have to make reservations
for parking like we did before during
the pandemic but boy we had 17 inches of
snow up there and the folks up there
were bragging about it and you should be
bragging because
you need to get open and get this season
going skiers and snowboarders have been
waiting so rabbit peak
that's the only slope that's over that's
the bunny hill so be it'll be a lot of
good skiing up there eventually and we
do have another chance for some mountain
snow next week so hopefully people will
take advantage of getting up there and
enjoying a look at the snow maybe
playing in it a little bit this weekend
but please be safe be careful on the
roads it is uh 20 degrees at kyle canyon
in the teens up there at lee canyon
right now and again they don't open
until 9 a.m 28 at red rock is going to
be a chilly bike ride if you're heading
out there to do the loop this morning or
go for a hike lots of 30's around the
valley very close to freezing in many
neighborhoods teens up in caliente in
lincoln county zero up the road in ely
this morning 28 mesquite we've got mid
30's boulder city to searchlight 46 and
windy already with north winds that will
increase as the day goes on in laughlin
18 in tonopah and 23 up the road in reno
and perum you're below freezing this
morning so our clouds clearing out from
yesterday we've had a little more
mountain snow across the intermountain
west but now that high pressure
continues to rebuild
the pressure gradients will tighten up
and that means northerly winds
strengthen there are lake wind
advisories and wind advisories all along
the colorado river valley today from 8
a.m to 7 p.m so a little more than an
hour from now the wind advisory will
start could see some 45 mile per hour
winds out there in those areas 35 just
for the high in kyle canyon today
but around freezing or maybe even not
even make it to freezing up there at lee
canyon so dress warm good gloves you
know the drill 25 mile per hour winds in
the mountains maybe some 20 mile per
hour breezes in the valley but good
sunshine now we haven't been in the 50s
for a few days we need to warm up a
little bit normal highs 56 we're hoping
for 53 to 54 today our last weekend of
fall looks nice and sunny but kind of
chilly morning still close to freezing
winter arrives tuesday morning and we
could see some sprinkles to a slight
chance of showers wednesday better
chance of rain and mountain snow
thursday before christmas eve
santa says i like to see some snow
before i get to las vegas on friday
night